do you have some uh because it's such a
monumental moment in our current history
as a quick
aside do you have thoughts about this
huge distributed crowdsourced
financial happenings uh with wall street
bets
that's like nobody could have well you
could have predicted but the scale and
the impact of this kind of emergent
behavior from
independent parties that could happen
like i said my own um
experience with the dismal science uh as
with physics led me to reject a lot of
bad models and
you know economics was always
compromised by politics
political economy um you could also
argue that it was it used to be a branch
of moral philosophy so it was concerned
with the good and
it became divorced and became sort of in
this quasi-newtonian way just about
everything's just running by itself
don't worry about it you know this is
not
crushing your netscape company but
that's just nature and economics
couldn't
or doesn't really have good models for
the wall street bets subreddit
you know they they know how to uh
squeeze a short right so
um the amazing thing is you have um
robinhood app which was again supposedly
for the demos for the people
yeah and eliminated the fee through
various kinds of
um you know straddles or some kind of
spread
operation that helped them eliminate the
fee or eat the fee
and in fact you know as a broker in
these days because it takes two days to
settle there's counterparty risk as
as they found out and um so the wall
street bets
uh people you know the the the memes are
like the
terminator robot with 600
stimmy check and the hedge funds the the
little girl hiding under the desk um
there there is a problem which i talked
about in the recent podcast which
i'm conscious of from the history of the
web and that is you could say it's
monopoly which
antitrust wasn't enforced after us from
microsoft for a long time
and um a lot of this was due to the
money interests buying
control of politicians and you know
in plato's five regimes that's oligarchy
that's that's that's where we are
and now we're seeing a fight against the
old arcs i don't know if it'll work but
you're definitely seeing it
and it's also kind of hackerish right
it's got a hacker ethos
you know hey robin hood no fees oh
interesting hey you know um
i could buy a fraction of a share in
this thing or i can keep buying
with my stimulus check so uh i mentioned
hegel seeing napoleon on the horse right
hegel also talked about the the cunning
of reason that you have
this sort of you know god sees history
in full and if you believe in god or
you know we don't know the future but
there's always this sort of fly in the
ointment this
uh unintended consequence uh that
confounds the best
um plans of the powers that be and we're
living through it that's
i'm glad it's not you know street
warfare or or
mechanized warfare because it has been
in the past um
it's it's more like soft power yes and
people are fighting back
you